nancy pelosi goes full marie antoinette
joe biden tries desperately to answer
basic questions and heads to kenosha and
president trump implies americans should
try to vote twice
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
standup for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
well it seems that there is this great
vast gap that has now emerged between
the so-called elites in our society
and everybody else and it's not really a
partisan gap so much as it is
a gap in mentality uh i've said before
that i think that we should be careful
of labeling people
elite versus elitist because there is a
difference and there are a lot of people
who are elite who are not elitists
and there are a lot of people who are
not particularly elite who are elitists
you know elite can be defined in many
ways
can be defined economically it can be
defined intellectually it can be defined
educationally but being an elitist is a
mentality that says the rules simply
don't apply to you because you are of
the special ilk
you are more special than everybody else
and
being an elitist also comes along with a
fair amount of dissociation
from things that you are not you right
you dissociate from things that are not
you you're not like
other human beings you are better than
other human beings and this
is mentality that has set in
particularly among the coastal
blue area elitists and it really is
having a vast impact on our politics and
there's been a lot of talk
in the past few years about why
president trump won in 2016.
and people seem to think that it's
because of a basket of economic policies
people who want to intellectualize
trump's victory
they'll say things like well you know
it's because he was for tariffs or
because president trump was harsh on
china or because he doesn't like illegal
immigration
they'll say it had something to do with
policy i think it has very very little
to do with policy and
a lot to do with a feeling from many
people in the middle of the country
that people who are in positions of
power don't
really care about people like them and
think that they are not held subject
to the same rules and and that is sort
of the the common theme
of modern american politics is the
people constantly being disappointed by
politicians
who suggest that they are one of the
people that they have a heart for the
people and then when it comes time to
actually apply the rules they don't
apply the rules
to themselves and this is why the story
of nancy pelosi going to get her hair
blow-dried in the middle of a pandemic
is is so
rich for republicans to mine because it
does demonstrate once again
that a lot of democrats who claim that
they have a heart for the people they
stand with the common man and they
really do not stand with the common man
and this is particularly true when it
comes to covid policy where
elitists ranging from neil ferguson the
modeler in the uk
to chris cuomo over at cnn to lori
lightfoot the mayor of chicago to
nancy pelosi believe that all of the
commoners have to be
pushed by the government into doing
things that destroy their own businesses
and their own livelihoods
that the people have to be led by the
hand and
that in fact the only way to absolve
yourself
is to do the political bidding of the
people who are setting the standard
meanwhile the elitists don't actually
have to abide by that standard
right the the leaders will tell you that
you can't hold a funeral for your parent
who died of covid or visit a parent with
coveted in the hospital
but you can definitely hold a protest
about systematic
systemic american injustice the same
people will tell you
that you can't open your business or
your church but they are fully able to
go to a
funeral for an important political
figure or in the case of neil ferguson
over in britain
meet with their married lover right
there are lots of things that the
elitists can do
that you simply cannot do and this is a
real gap in mentality and it is bred
by a certain segment of american society
that declares itself part of a
meritocracy but then takes the concept
of meritocracy
to the ultimate extreme where the people
who are on the top of the quote-unquote
meritocracy get to run everybody else's
lives see
the thing about a meritocracy is that
you're not supposed to be able to shut
the door behind you you're not supposed
to bring up the ladder behind you the
latter
that goes from the attic of the
meritocracy down into the rest of the
house and yet elitists want to do
exactly that because
they are the top of the meritocracy they
want to shut the door behind them
and then run everybody else's life from
atop that pyramid
it's i've told the story before how when
i when i first attended harvard law
school which is
you know the top of the meritocracy you
only get in if you score above 172 on
the lsats essentially and you have a 4.0
gpa and you have a bunch of great
extracurriculars
and the the very first day that i'm at
harvard law school
we sat down for orientation in this
beautiful ballroom looks like something
out of harry potter
and elena kagan who is then the dean of
harvard law school now of course on the
supreme court
she gets up and she says the competition
is over
harvard law school is the source of a
bunch of supreme court justices harvard
law school is the source of x number of
senators and x number of congress people
and the sitting presidents of the united
states uh well at the time it would have
been
the future president of the united
states barack obama went to harvard law
school
hubbard law school is the center of
power and the competition is now over it
doesn't matter how you do in this school
because your opportunities are limitless
in the future
you are the rulers of the universe i
believe that was the exact phrase she is
you're the rulers of the universe
even if you don't believe it you are
well that sort of
marie antoinette feeling that belief
that because you're at the top of the
heap you get to run things for everybody
else
that is deeply off-putting to most
americans and that's why
nancy pelosi what she did here i
understand that it's not a
world-breaking story but it is
indicative of
a mentality that is cursing american
politics and has led to tremendous
splits in american life and it does have
a connection to the structure of
american government
see it's not as though ambitious
politicians haven't always wanted to
control people's lives
they always have the founders recognize
this this is exactly why they set up a
system of checks and balances
that devolved most power to the local
level the idea was that the most
ambitious
ambition would check ambition in the
words of the federalist papers
that checks and balances would prevent
people who are ambitious from running
your life
that government would by its it's very
grind
prevent people at the top from running
your life but what we have seen
increasingly
is a demand by the american people
simultaneously that the elitists not run
their life but also that the elitists
give them everything they could possibly
want and these two
i would say gut level reactions cannot
coexist logically
they cannot operate morally and so what
you get is people electing elitists to
run their life and then objecting when
the elitists run their life
well the american people have a choice
don't elect elitists don't elect
elitists and particularly don't electing
leaders who wish to
wash away all of those checks and
balances that actually allow you to live
your life
on a local level without having to worry
about the nancy pelosi's of the world
see i wouldn't care if nancy pelosi were
a normal person
going to get her hair did at the local
hair salon i don't care about that
in fact i can tell you i live in l.a l.a
county has been shut down for months on
end
and i will tell you there's an awful lot
of bootleg nail saloning and
heritage is getting dead right i mean
that that is that is happening a lot
in l.a county i i tend to work out
outdoors at a gym a local gym and a
couple doors down
there is a completely papered over hair
salon and
that hair salon is wide open right they
just papered over the front windows
and people are going in every day
there's this bootleg business that's
going on because it turns out people
cannot survive
based on the nancy pelosi standard so if
it were just somebody going to get their
hair done i wouldn't i wouldn't really
care but if we're talking about people
setting standards
and sharing standards and and yelling at
people
about their inability to follow those
standards and then applying a different
standard to themselves that's a very
very different story and that's why the
nancy pelosi story matters because it is
indicative
of a broader trend in american public
life elitists running your life getting
rid of all obstacles to running your
life
believing that if they have any sort of
majority power
they can cram down their agenda on
everybody else but then not applying the
rules to themselves
that's the part americans are objecting
to and that really was the rebellion
in favor of donald trump in 2016. and
honestly it's that sort of feeling that
is going to drive if trump wins a
re-election victory it's going to drive
that as well
you're seeing it in everything from
nancy pelosi's activity to all of these
ridiculous
new york intellectual types who are
taking pictures of themselves eating
outdoors in new york going everything's
fine here i don't see why everybody's
complaining about the crime and about
the
economy everything's fine i'm sitting
right outside here drinking a fruity
drink
i mean i'm not kidding there's a guy
named gary steingart and gary steingart
literally tweeted out a picture of
himself drinking a fruity drink
outdoors to demonstrate that everything
is totally fine
he is a quote-unquote book writer gary
steingard and
he uh he took a picture of himself
outside in new york and tweeted had to
shoot my way through a whole bunch of
antifa roadblocks but it was worth it to
get this
fruity drink okay it's that elitist
mentality
that is that is leading to this vast
culture gap more than anything else
and that's partially a class gap well
we'll talk more about this in just one
second because we're going to get to
nancy pelosi
who is now attempting to destroy the
business she's attempting to destroy the
hair salon she went to
because she would not abide by the rules
that she cheers we'll get to that in
just one second first
let's talk about the fact that you hate
overpaying your phone bill like
there's no reason to spend extra money
on your phone bill think of all the
money you automatically give away
every month taxes obviously but then
internet cable utilities bills you put
them on your auto pay and then you
forget about them and then you look up
at the end of the year and you've spent
thousands of dollars on your phone bill
atm 18t verizon t-mobile they all want
to charge you for data and perks that
you never use
thankfully there is pure talk usa
puretalk gives you the exact same
coverage same towers same bars but cost
you half with no contract and no
excessive fees
right now enjoy unlimited talk text and
two gigs of data all for just 20 bucks a
month the average person
is saving 400 a year on their wireless
bill so grab your mobile phone
dial pal 250 say ben shapiro when you do
you'll save 250 bucks off any iphone
including the new iphone se
again that is pound two five zero say
keyword ben shapiro to save money
on your wireless bill and you're
probably spending a lot of money for
data that you don't actually need
so why not pare down that bill and use
the money for all sorts of goodies out
there there's just
plenty of deals out there right now that
you can use that money for so why would
you waste it on your phone company
pure talk usa simply smarter wireless
again pure talk usa
and dialpound250 say keyword ben shapiro
to get started
okay so here is the story with nancy
pelosi so i'm assuming that people know
the story but the story is
that she visited a san francisco hair
salon in person
in defiance of local coronavirus
restrictions and then
when she was caught on tape doing this
she then turned around and accused the
business of setting her up
she accused the business of setting her
up i wasn't expecting the merry and
berry type
full-on i've been set up when i was
found with a coke a briefcase full of
cocaine in my room
but this is this is pretty stellar stuff
so nancy pelosi
her net worth is i believe 300 million
something like that her husband is
extraordinarily wealthy
and nancy pelosi is also the lady who is
spotted on late night tv in the middle
of pandemic standing in front of a
subzero 20 000
fridge eating custom-made gelato
but she's a woman of the people right
she cares deeply about the people does
nancy pelosi so finally she was asked
about this yesterday
and her initial response was not yes i'm
a hypocrite
i understand a lot of businesses are
suffering i shouldn't have done that
you know my better sense was overcome
instead
she went after the business she said
that she takes responsibility for being
set up
being set up so mary antoinette has
hired legal counsel we'll get to that in
a second she actually hired a lawyer
to put out a letter explaining that the
business owner set her up here's nancy
pelosi claiming that she was the victim
of a setup
when she scheduled an appointment at a
hair salon in defiance of local
coronavirus restrictions again
everyone in california knows about these
restrictions the notion that nancy
pelosi is ignorant of the restrictions
is patently crazy i mean really really
nuts
everybody in california knows about this
because everything's closed you can
drive down the street and you can see
that everything is closed okay and if
you don't know the local restrictions
then what you send what you typically
tend to do is call up
the business owner and ask what the
local restrictions are not what they are
doing
what the local restrictions are and if
you are one of the lawmakers who is the
most pro-lockdown lawmakers in the
united states
you would assume that at some point you
might ask oh what are the local
restrictions she knows what they are
just doesn't care because she's an
important person
she's a vip all animals are created
equal but some animals are more equal
than others and nancy pelosi
titha clackin is the most equal of all
so here's nancy pelosi explaining that
she was set up
i can't believe they set me up says
nancy pelosi
i take responsibility for trusting the
word of the neighborhood salon that i've
been to
over the years many times and
that when they said what we're able to
accommodate people one person at a time
and that we can set up that time i
trusted that
as it turns out it was a setup so i take
responsibility
for falling for a setup i think that
this
salon owes me an apology though solano's
her apology
she takes responsibility for falling for
a setup it was a sting
operation to get nancy pelosi now
um it seems to me that as the speaker of
the house you should probably know the
local ordinances
with regard to whether she's allowed to
go to the local salon even by herself
considering they are all closed
in the city of san francisco and that
we've seen tents popping out
on the sidewalks everywhere in
california where people
are getting their hair done outside but
now she's going to blame the business
the the business owner woman named erica
kia she's the owner of isilon
she blasted pelosi on fox news she said
it was a slap in the face she went in
you know that she feels she can just go
and get her stuff done while no one else
can go in and i can't work
we're supposed to look up to this woman
right it's just disturbing so she
appeared
did erica kiyas on tucker carlson's show
last night
and she said well no i mean this was not
a setup she's been coming in for quite a
while and she set up the appointment
herself or her assistant did so i'm not
sure how this is a setup exactly
she's been coming in for quite a while
and
just to see her come in and especially
not wearing the mask that's what really
got to me but
you know this isn't even political i
mean she's been coming in there it's the
fact that she actually came
in and
didn't have a mask on and i just thought
about you know my staff and people
not being able to work and make money
and provide for their families and
if she's in there comfortably without a
mask and feeling safe then why
are we shut down why am i not able to
have clients come in
so nancy pelosi responds to this by
sicking her lawyers on the salon
because she is not only an elitist to
whom the rules don't apply
she also can afford very expensive
lawyers to go after local business
owners whose businesses are shut down
and the lawyer letter is so incredible
because the lawyer letter basically says
look at this terrible business woman who
behind closed doors has been doing
business
which nancy pelosi was taking advantage
of okay
that's that's wild and kind of hilarious
pelosi spokesperson by the way denied
the original allegations she told fox
news well drew drew hamill her spokesman
told fox news quote the speaker always
wears a mask and complies with local
covered requirements
rongo rongo but hamill then
it continued this business offered for
the speaker to come in on monday and
told her they were allowed by the city
to have one customer at a time in the
business
the speaker complied with the rules as
presented to her by this establishment
so um yeah not not too much
not too much okay so we'll get to nancy
pelosi sicking her
daughter and her lawyer on this whole
thing in just one second it's pretty
amazing we'll get to that in just one
second first
let's talk about the fact that it is
pretty easy to have your information
stolen online it's happened to me i
remember a couple of years ago
before i started using expressvpn i was
online and suddenly i started getting
charges from people buying
super like like nfl tickets and i
thought to myself i haven't been to an
nfl game recently or
maybe ever and it turned out somebody
had hacked my credit card
information well expressvpn helps
prevent stuff like that
not too long ago over 100 million people
had their personal information stolen in
a major data breach
social security numbers contact details
credit scores and more all taken from
capital one customers it's not just
capital one
equifa equifax ebay uber playstation
yahoo they've all had
passwords leaked credit card information
leaked bank numbers belonging to
billions of users hacked
if you think hackers only target large
companies wrong it's just that you don't
have a giant
ip uh you don't have a giant pro
intellectual property department working
for you and i t department working for
you to protect your data that's why you
need
expressvpn expressvpn it's an app for
your computer and phone that secures and
encrypts your data so you can have peace
of mind every time you go online the app
connects with just one click it's
lightning fast the best part
expressvpn costs less than seven bucks a
month listen if a breach can happen to
capital one it can certainly happen if
it can happen to me it can happen to you
go check out expressvpn.com they're the
people i trust
use my special link expressvpn.com right
now
arm yourself with an extra three months
of expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com
ben for an extra three months for free
the last thing you need is to have your
information hacked it's happened to me
i've used expressvpn doesn't have
it doesn't happen to me anymore go check
them out expressvpn.com for an extra
three months
for free okay so nancy pelosi has
responded to this not just by claiming
she was set up but then
she hired an attorney to write a letter
to the salon threatening to sue
and so here is the letter from matthew
suleiman poor esquire
this office represents the interests of
jonathan dinardo a california certified
cosmetologist
based out of san francisco california in
response to press inquiries on the
matter then mr donato can confirm that
he did indeed provide professional
stylist services to house speaker nancy
pelosi on august 31st 2020
at the esalon located at 2288 union
street in san francisco california
mr dinardo at all times took all
requisite safety measures throughout his
appointment with speaker pelosi
including sanitation of all service
areas and wearing of cvc recommended
protective equipment
mr dinardo has worked at easilon for
approximately six years and regularly
communicates with the salon owner erica
quias
in fact mr donato received advance
approval from miss kias the day prior to
the appointment during a telephone
discussion on august 29
2020 at 9 26 p.m when mr dinardo advised
ms kias he would not proceed with
speaker pelosi's appointment without
miss
mr kia mr kia's authorization ms kias
took special interest in the appointment
during the telephone call when she made
several vitriolic and incendiary
comments about speaker pelosi
and her purported responsibility for
temporarily suspending operations
of miss kia's or mischievous business
despite such orders actually being put
into place not by pelosi but by governor
gavin newsom and san francisco mayor
london breed
ultimately kies authorized order to
proceed with speaker pelosi's
appointment
this office is in possession of
photographs videos and witness
information that ms kia's
prior contrary to her prior statements
to the press has actually been operating
her business during the stay at home
orders in similar executive orders
limiting in-store operations since as
far back as april 2020. okay so now it
is not only that pelosi is suggesting
that kia said she could come in
and then kia's tape turn released the
tape which by the way is still not a
sting operation
because there's an obligation for pelosi
not to violate the law
even if somebody says to you you can
come into my gym or my hair salon it's
totally full we're operating
you know we're operating at full
capacity it is your responsibility not
to violate the law speaker pelosi that's
not how any of this works
you don't get to simply say well the
business said it was okay so it's
probably okay
that is not how this works especially
not if you're speaker of the house
ignorance is not an excuse by the way
she's not ignorant about any of this
but beyond that she is now attempting to
destroy the business of this person
why well she's gonna now say well she
was violating the orders all along
okay so here's the question if your case
is that she was violating the orders all
along
then which is that bad or is that okay
because you're also violating the orders
so either it was bad in which case you
are bad or it was fine in which case you
should relieve the lockdowns
in the first place but instead they're
going to try and get kious cited
for violations by the local city
government in response to nancy pelosi
being complicit in the violations
according to this lawyer again the fact
that kias is now objecting to speaker
pelosi's presence at the isilon from a
simple surface level review
of miss kia's political leanings it
appears miss kies is furthering a setup
of speaker pelosi for her own
vain aspirations oh yes
when i think of vain vanity aspirations
i think
i think of a a local salon owner trying
to keep her business owner i don't think
of the highly botoxed
gelato eating sub-zero standing in front
of
hair dry speaker of the house who has to
appear on msnbc that night because the
rules don't apply
to people like nancy pelosi good
good stuff right there very very good
stuff and here's the thing
it is this elitist attitude toward
fellow americans
that is built into so much of our
politics it is not just about nancy
pelosi it's also built into the issues
surrounding race
in the united states so much of our
racial conversation right now
the racial conversation that is driving
incredible wedges in the united states
let's not pretend that the racial
conversations that are happening right
now are productive they're not
productive
they're not helpful they're not
productive they've not made america
better
by pulling data black and white are more
separated than at any time in modern
recent history
and there's a reason for that it's
because the racial conversations that
are happening right now
are predicated on the very basic notion
that unless you're an elitist
white liberal who has dissociated from
your own white supremacy
then you can't be part of the
conversation and in fact the people who
ought to be leading this conversation
are those people are the elitist white
liberals they're the ones with the work
to do which means moral authority and
responsibility
lies with them and this is how you end
up with
all of these incredibly wealthy powerful
white liberals who are now putting out
these kind of
maoist struggle session statements
talking about their own racism
dissociating from other white americans
who presumably are just the little
people right the little people
who are implicitly racist right let me
tell you something the unemployed
the unemployed welder in appalachia is
not sitting around thinking about his
white privilege today
you know why because that person doesn't
have white privilege that person doesn't
have a lot of privilege
at all in fact it turns out that the
very basic notion of white privilege
is being substituted for what is
commonly known as class privilege
meaning
it is better to be wealthy than it is to
be poor but instead we have decided to
speak solely in terms of race
because what that what does that allow
it allows white rich liberals to pretend
that they are not at the top of the
hierarchy that in fact if they
disassociate
they can be they can be granted moral
authority once more
and this is how you end up with chelsea
clinton going around talking
about how she wants her white children
of privilege to erode that privilege
moral authority being confirmed once
again on chelsea clinton
now chelsea clinton does have privilege
it doesn't have to do with a race
it has to do with the fact that she is
the daughter of a president and the
former secretary of state
and and near second in your first female
president right chelsea clinton is one
of those privileged people in the
history of america
but that is not because she is white
there are plenty of people
who are white who are not privileged the
way that chelsea clinton is privileged
but here's the thing by suggesting that
she is
suffering from white privilege she then
gets to be the good white person
now she doesn't get to be the person who
shouldn't have to be the person who is
condemned
for living an elitist life while
dictating rules to everybody else
she gets to disassociate from the other
white people who are the bad white
people while she
the cream of the crop gets to dictate
rules for everybody else on behalf of
white people everywhere so here's
chelsea clinton speaking on behalf of
white people everywhere and also
suggesting that she's going to
indoctrinate her children into this
cultish belief
in racial essentialism in states where
there haven't been
kind of no excuse absentee voting or
whether
you know hasn't been the introduction of
early voting yet you know
it still isn't um kind of easy
fair or equal for many americans to vote
i think it's really important that my
children understand that and i think
it's particularly important that they
understand that
as white children of privilege because i
want them to erode that privilege
throughout their lives to ensure more
people are
enfranchised and that equality isn't
just an ideal
okay and then she's talking to ayanna
presley who promptly taps her on the
head
and confers the the wands of magic
anti-racism
upon her and says you're really modeling
that which my mother certainly believed
which is that a parent is a child's
first teacher i appreciate you're
providing that full education we know
that often there's a revisionist history
of sanitizing a filtering of history
that does not tell the whole story
confronting that past that's really how
we get to truth
and reconciliation no it isn't no it
isn't because that's not what you're
talking about doing you're not talking
about
you're not talking about looking at
american history with an eye toward all
of the dark parts you're talking about
completely rewriting american history so
that america
is thoroughly racist except for
wonderful people like ayanna pressley
who has ultimate racial privilege
in terms of how she gets to speak about
race and chelsea clinton who now gets to
enter
that coterie of people we should listen
to because she has disassociated from
other white people and alleviated her
own
internalized white guilt in a second
we're going to get to more of this
elitist perspective on race because most
americans i think who are not elitist
don't tend to walk around thinking about
their race
all day i think the people who are
thinking about race the most are the
people at the top
of the intellectual hierarchy the people
who graduated from the good schools and
got indoctrinated
in their in their critical studies
theory and and now they are the ones who
are determining what the moral standards
should be for everybody else there's
there's elitism when it comes to
discussions of race that is completely
separated from the realities
of everyday human beings in the united
states we'll get to that in just one
second first
let us talk about the fact that hiring
can be very difficult without any
assistance
it's really hard i mean very difficult
because again you have to sit through a
ton of resumes
many of them are not very good you can't
remember where you can put the resumes
it's hard to keep track of all this
stuff
and you might not even be soliciting
resumes from the right crowd this is why
you need zip recruiters zip recruiter
will send your job to over 100 of the
web's leading job sites but they don't
stop there
with their powerful matching technology
ziprecruiter scans thousands of resumes
to find people with the right experience
and then actively invites them to apply
to your job ziprecruiter makes hiring
efficient and effective with features
like screening questions to filter out
candidates and an all-in-one dashboard
where you can review and rate your
candidates as well
ziprecruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day i mean assume for a
second
that you had a a producer and that
producer was supposed to send you
ads but they were supposed to do it like
well before the show and they only did
it like two seconds before the show or
maybe even in the middle of the show
and then you were suddenly supposed to
come up with the ads on your own and
this happened like every single day
well then you might go to producer
colton and say listen zip recruiter is
for you zip recruiter you can try it for
free my listeners can go to
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e
ziprecruiter.com daily wire zip recorder
is indeed
the smartest way to hire okay so again
this view of race in america
is being driven very often by the
elitist so singer demi lovato
is now opening up about the shame she
feels for her white privilege
and how she changed her social advocacy
because she's one of the good ones right
she's an elitist
she gets to determine how we all think
about race which is really really
exciting stuff
now i think the way that normal people
generally ought to think about race
is that race is not a primary secondary
or tertiary consideration in how you
determine
the worth of another human being and
this this also happened to be the
perspective on racism for a long time in
the united states before we decided
that racial essentialism was the key and
that implicitly we all judge each other
based on race and thus
we must think in terms of how to elevate
groups rather than how to grant rights
for individuals
so now demi lovato she's separated off
from her racial privilege
and she too gets to be one of the
elitist coterie who the rules don't
apply to her she can talk about races
freely as she wants to talk about it
because she has now been conferred
legitimacy by vogue magazine
so she wrote in vogue and she lamented
for several paragraphs her own ongoing
struggles
and then she started talking about race
she says
looking back on 2020 it's been a year of
great change that helped her realize how
much more she should be doing to help
other people
she said i've always taken my advocacy
work seriously now i'm looking at it
with renewed focus
in this particular instance what
motivated me was knowing how much of
myself comes from black culture
i grew up listening to aretha franklin
whitney houston and other soulful
singers but those two black women in
particular
shaped me into the vocalist i am if you
look at my life everything i have money
success a roof over my head
it's because of the inspiration those
black women gave me i continue to be
constantly inspired by people of color
today so here i am
sitting in a home i was able to afford
with the money that i have from singing
while people of color are fearing for
their lives
every day i realized this was a
lightning bolt jolting through my body
where i was reminded of my privilege
i felt an overwhelming responsibility to
help spread awareness about this
injustice so i began posting things i
thought would educate
people all i knew is that was that i
hated that i shared the same skin color
as the people accused of committing
heinous crimes against ahmedabary briana
taylor george floyd and many many other
black lives
after taking some time to educate myself
what i've learned is that to be a good
ally
you need to be willing to protect people
at all costs and it's not just with
black lives matter it's with me too
finally the world is waking up so this
is the way this works is that the
elitists in our society get to determine
exactly how we ought to view questions
of race
and there are and this has become
implicit
in the democratic party agenda it's not
just elitist views of coveted where the
rules don't apply to them
if you're a democratic politician the
rules don't apply to you either so if
you're joe biden you could be called a
racist by kamala harris a year ago
and now you're a leader on racial
justice issues how
well you just declared that america is
systemically racist and now you are
dedicated to fighting that systemic
racism
now as i have pointed out the shift in
definition
from racism to systemic racism is wrong
stupid and ugly okay racism was
originally defined as the belief in the
inferiority or superiority of a group of
people based on race
that was the definition of racism and
you could tell a racist policy if it
distinguished it based on race
you could tell a racist if a racist did
a racist thing but then
in the 1960s the definition of race
shifted
and racism particularly shifted stokely
carmichael who became the head of the
black panther party
stokley carmichael originally one of the
heads of uh of
another prominent civil rights
organization then he became radicalized
he he redefined racism he he said that
racism actually was any system that
creates inequality and this is exactly
the argument that is made today
see i don't think the american people
understand what definitional shift has
happened here
i think that the american people look at
phrases and they under they identify the
word they understand
and then they forget the modifier so you
see this happen with social justice
people say yeah i'm for social justice
and what they think they mean
is they're just for justice they don't
understand that the word social has now
modified the word justice so justice
when most people think
about it justice is just about an
individual getting what they deserve
social justice is about a group getting
what the quote unquote group deserves
in spite of what the individual actually
deserves so social justice is actually
in many ways the opposite of individual
justice the same thing is true
of racial justice or environmental
justice whenever you add a modifier to
justice what you're actually doing
is shifting the definition from an
inherently individual definition of
justice
to another definition of justice that
implicitly condones
injustice against individuals okay the
same thing happens when you're talking
about racism
so racism is bad right racism is wrong
because racism again
is defined as the belief in the
inferiority or superiority of a group of
people based solely on race that is the
definition
of racism systemic racism is the
suggestion
that you don't actually have to be
conscious of your own racism you don't
have to be a racist you don't have to
have done anything racist you don't have
to be complicit in a quote-unquote
racist policy
that is directed specifically at
subjugating people of a particular race
you don't have to do any of that
systemic racism is the idea that any
system
that creates any inequality between
races is in fact racist
and if you're complicit in that system
then even if you are not a racist
you're complicit in racism right you're
basically
like a brown shirt in the nazi system
are you
there are no good germans or if there
are good germans then they are complicit
in the nazi system
the same thing is true of system
systematically racist and systemically
racist systems
so systemic has now completely shifted
the definition of racism to the point
where you are now personally held
responsible
for systems even if you yourself have
not done anything wrong
thomas soul recently suggested we have
now reached a point in american life
where nobody is held
responsible for the decisions they make
but everybody is held responsible for
the decisions others make
and i think that that is basically
correct and this is the perspective
taken up by the elitists
because one of the beautiful thing about
being an elitist is that you have
relieved yourself of individual
responsibility by condemning the system
and now you get to reshape the entire
system because you've condemned the
system
and you also get to ignore the plight of
individuals you don't have to focus in
on individuals you get to
because again focus on individuals
places a responsibility where it truly
lies
with people making individual decisions
focus on systems especially free systems
tends to result in your ability to shirk
your own responsibility for your own
actions
and instead you get to campaign against
systems from which you can dissociate
which is a very self-esteem boosting way
of viewing the world and it's one of the
reasons why the democratic party has
fully embraced this sort of language
so joe biden recently put out an ad the
ad that he put out
was all about how black americans are
systemically discriminated against in
the united states now joe biden
again five seconds ago he's being called
a racist by kamala harris but now he's
one of the goodies
because he's dissociated from the
systemic racism of the american system
that he implicitly wants to preserve and
run
here was this ad from from the biden
campaign
why in this nation and black americans
wake up knowing that they can lose their
life
in the course of just living their life
part of the point of freedom is to be
free from brutality from injustice from
racism
and all of its manifestations we have to
let people know
that we not only understand their
struggle but they understand the fact
they deserve to be treated with dignity
they've got to know
we're listening reforming policing in
this country
means creating a national standard on
use of force
okay again the original statement here
before she gets to the policing reform
that the democrats shot down
when tim scott the black senator from
south carolina who's a republican
proposed it
the actual thing they're pushing here is
again the idea that you are in implicit
danger if you're a black person in
america that is not true there are 42
black
42 million black people living in the
united states the number of unarmed
black people who are shot and killed
every year by the police numbers
every year under 20 out of 42 million
people that doesn't mean that the police
aren't sometimes brutal there are cases
where the police
engage in police brutality and there are
investigations of that
and there should be investigations of
that but again the widespread narrative
here
is the elitist narrative on race which
is that only the elitists can solve
that the hard work of racial tolerance
isn't done on the individual level where
you
work and you work to train your kids so
that they treat
everybody equally and they treat
everybody well instead the hard work is
done at the top level by the elitists
who get to control the entire system
that is the implicit message here so
we'll get to more of this in just one
second because it's fairly obvious that
the facts do not matter
if you are of the belief that that
narrative is the case then you don't
even have to care about the individual
facts of particular police situations
you can simply label the entire system
racist and as we'll see that's exactly
what joe biden has been doing to
truly ugly effect we'll get to that in
one moment first let us talk about the
fact
that you know these days a lot of people
thinking about life insurance i mean we
got a coveted pandemic
we've got riots in america's major
cities we've got increased shootings
like
it's a pretty dark time in american
history and a lot of people are thinking
can i even get life insurance the answer
of course is you can indeed get life
insurance i have life insurance you
should have life insurance if you're a
responsible human being
and policy genius is the easiest and
best way to get life insurance right now
you could save 1500 bucks or more a year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies when you're shopping
for a policy that could last for a
decade or more
those savings really start to add up
what is policy genius well it's an
insurance marketplace
built and backed by a team of industry
experts here's how it works step one
you head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top insurers to find your best
price
step two you can apply for your lowest
price step three the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork
and the red tape policy genius works for
you not the insurance company so
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they'll take care of
everything for you
they even have policies that allow
eligible customers to skip that
in-person medical exam and do it over
the phone which these days is really
really convenient if you need life
insurance head on over to
policygenius.com
right now to get started you could say
1500 bucks or more per year by comparing
quotes on their insurance marketplace
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice
and important to get it right okay we're
going to get to more of this in
just one second the the elitist
narrative on race
being fostered by npr being fostered by
the biden
campaign and it has real consequences
for real people living in the united
states
particularly and disproportionately
minority americans we'll get that in a
second first
as part of our daily wear audience there
are a number of ways you can take in the
podcast you can listen on apple podcast
on spotify or another podcast app
you can also watch our podcast on
youtube facebook over at dailywire.com
here's the bottom line we are making our
content available to you anywhere you
watch or listen and right now we're
introducing a new upgraded experience
daily wear is now on apple tv and roku
so members can enjoy
all of the magnificent visual elements
of this podcast on your big screen
either live or on demand
find the daily wire on apple tv or roku
and download today you have to be an
insider member to watch live so head on
over to dailywire.com
shapiro use code watch at checkout to
get 15 off your membership purchase
the deal is not going to last long so
act fast if you want live shows on your
big screen plus the one of a kind highly
coveted leftist tears tumblr
again that is dailywire.com shapiro to
get 15
off with code watch and download the
daily wear on your apple tv and roku
today
another big announcement for you gang
the ben shapiro show sunday special it's
back
and better than ever this week with an
all new episode featuring
candace owens i know a lot of people
have been clamoring for this we'll be
talking about the 2020 election
george floyd cardi b and tons of other
good stuff so do not miss out this
sunday
september 6th you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
okay so again the the view of the
elitists in the united states is that
they get to set the standard for
everybody else
and they have to do the hard work just
give them all the power and they will
fix everything
that's the logic here right the systems
are wrong but you the little
the peons you can't fix the systems only
the people at the top can fix the
systems and the systems don't apply to
them because they've dissociated from
the systems so nancy pelosi doesn't have
to abide by coveted rules she's a
special joe biden
doesn't have to abide by any of the
rules of racism he can randomly walk
around the united states talking about
how
indian people all own 7-elevens yes
that's a thing he did and
he's totally it's fine it's fine the
system doesn't apply to him
because he is separate from the system
because he is a part because he is
better he's above
the system our elitist they run the
system you the peons you just get peed
on
and what this means is that if you are
joe biden then
you really don't ever have to examine
the facts of any particular case or
treat people as individuals what this
really
means in essence when elitists set the
system is that individuals don't matter
they get to set how you live because
they are important
and you are not and they know better
because they are rich and because they
are smart and because they are famous
and because they've been thrust into
positions of power okay so yesterday joe
biden
finally does a press conference it's a
very bizarre press conference
it's bizarre because he doesn't actually
call on people the way that president
trump does
you can say a lot of things about trump
but trump has done a lot of pressers
he'll stand out there he'll answer
questions for hours dude loves the
attention from the media joe biden
has been hiding in his hidey hole and
he's been he's been doing the spider
whole thing
and and now he emerges like the
groundhog
once every six weeks or so and we
determine whether there are another
several weeks of winter or not he
emerges he doesn't actually
just point to people in the crowd
instead they have a pre-selected list of
people
who are attending these press
conferences and then the staff calls on
these people
and so as you will see what asked a
tough question biden had no answer to it
we'll get to that in a second but
here is joe biden's take on the jacob
blake and brianna taylor cases
as i say the reason this is indicative
of a broader mindset is because
if you believe the system of policing in
the united states is inherently racist
you never have to consider the
individual facts of the case
right joe biden is set to go to kenosha
today he's going to meet with the family
of jacob blake
forget the fact that jacob blake senior
the the person he's meeting with is
apparently like a rabid anti-semite
there are a bunch of social media posts
that have come out but frankly that's
that's not super
important other than it's very awkward
for biden but i guess not so awkward
the real problem is why is he meeting
with the family of a guy who
who was they attempted to arrest him
because a woman called the police that
woman
had been an alleged prior victim of
sexual assault by jacob blake
she called the cops because he allegedly
broke into her home
and sexually violated her with his
finger while
her children were asleep in the same
room she called the cops the cops
arrived he attempts to
avoid arrest he attempts to resist
arrest he walks around to the driver's
side of his car he reaches in
and a knife is found on the floorboard
of the driver's side of his car there
are three kids in the back of the car
and they're the bad according to joe
biden
those officers should just be charged
based on what evidence we don't know
according to joe biden the brianna
taylor officer should be charged does
not matter
that a tragic situation does not
necessarily mean somebody did anything
criminal
in the brianna taylor case they had a
39-page supporting document
that suggested that brianna taylor was
in fact involved with her ex-boyfriend's
drug trafficking there's a lot of
supporting evidence to this they took
out a no-knock warrant
on that basis there's no evidence the
police officers thought that that
no knock warrant was fraudulent they did
knock according to the police officers
they did knock in fact
and then after they knocked the people
inside so they didn't announce
themselves after they knocked
then they started to force the door as a
no knock warrant would suggest
they were shot at by brianna taylor's
current boyfriend
at which point they tried to shoot the
boyfriend and instead they hit brianna
taylor that's a tragic terrible
situation
but that is not necessarily a criminal
situation in fact it's very difficult to
think
of a way you could charge the officers
in that case nonetheless because the
facts of the case don't matter
joe biden is now suggesting that all of
these officers should be charged why
because while joe biden insists that
cops are mostly good they work for a
systemically racist system of course
here was joe biden pushing this message
yesterday
last week your running mate senator
harris said that the officer who shot
jacob blake
based on what she has seen should be
charged do you agree with her and do you
also believe the same for the officers
who were involved in the death of
brianna taylor
i think we should let the judicial
system
work its way i do think there's a
minimum need to be charged the officers
and as well as brianna taylor so we
should let the judicial system work its
magic but also they should be charged
that's not how the judicial judicial
system works
why should they be charged you just said
you wanted the process to work but then
you said you don't want the process to
work because they should be charged in
the absence of evidence because again
the system is bad sometimes i think that
people on the right are
engaged in a fool's errand trying to
actually do the work sometimes it's not
just people on the right anybody with a
semblance of brain power
that we're we're engaged in a fool's
errand trying to actually distinguish
between cases
when people like joe biden are
suggesting no distinctions are necessary
and this is one of my pet peeves
is the suggestion by people like joe
biden that people like michael brown
were innocent victims of the cops
and they lump in michael brown with
ahmed arberry who's actually the victim
of a murder
right like why exactly are all these
cases lumped together because again
the implicit answer is it's the system
and people like joe biden should run the
system so they can run your
life too we shouldn't treat people as
individuals this is how you end up with
the media
treating two very separate cases very
similarly today
so there are big protests in washington
dc last night there was a black man
named dion k
who was shot and he was killed in
washington dc
he was shot and killed because
apparently he was
riding around the neighborhood and
wielding a gun
and then he brandished a firearm and
pointed it at the cops and then he was
shot
okay so that and then they they released
pictures of the handguns that that had
been found
on the on the people uh who are running
away from the police
that case has prompted a lot of angst in
washington dc
that seems to me a particularly
non-controversial case but then there
are actual controversial cases
that require serious attention and are
getting serious attention because we
still live in a country with
individual justice and due process of
law so for example there's a case out of
rochester new york it looks really ugly
on the face of it
in which there was a black man named
daniel prude who apparently was high on
pcp according to the coroner's report
and was acting crazy and his brother
apparently called the police
he was 41 he was running around
rochester new york in the middle of
winter
completely naked the police arrive and
they
arrest him and the tape is really
disturbing because they arrest him he
appears to be basically complying but he
is delusional
and he suggests that he wants to take
their guns but he's not really making a
move toward it
they they put a spit bag over his head
there's the middle uh this is the
beginning of the coronavirus pandemics
this happened back
all the way in march they put a spit bag
over his head those are breathable
apparently and um and then he starts to
kind of move and they jump on top of him
and he stops breathing
right so it's a bad situation all around
like this is an actual controversial
case but we're not supposed to
distinguish between cases
we're supposed to pretend that all the
cases are exactly the same well you know
what a rational
country would do you know what rational
people would do again on race
on covet on everything we would treat
people individually but we don't we
treat people collectively so the
powerful can run our lives
here's a tape of an of a situation that
requires investigation and
in fact is in fact being investigated
right now
okay there is an investigation that is
that is taking place
so here is a little bit of this tape
it's disturbing
get on the ground man no get on the
ground put your hands behind your back
so there he is complying he puts his
hand behind his back
don't move completely naked i mean
they put the spit
and so they put him back down on the
ground and then they uh subdue him
and they hold him down and he's held
down on the ground and then eventually
he stops breathing
the emts arrive on site
uh he's using a knee uh that's because
again
by most police department uses a force
if somebody's in a sighted delirium
state this is a way of subduing
the person but did he need to be subdued
that way
who the hell i'm gonna go no on that
right i mean this looks
somewhat like george floyd now in this
case the actual coroner's report unlike
the george floyd case where they said
that
asphyxiation had nothing to do with it
in this particular case
um the suggestion was that asphyxiation
did have something to do with it the
medical examiner ruled the death of
homicide by complications of asphyxia
in the setting of physical restraint
worth noting the rochester police chief
lauren singletary who is black
said this is not a cover-up we released
the tape
and uh leticia james is the new york ag
said the death of daniel prude was a
tragedy i extend my deepest condolences
to the family
i share the community's concerns about
ensuring a fair and independent
investigation into his death
and support their rights to protest
we'll follow the facts of the case
ensure a complete and thorough
examination of all the relevant parties
okay now that is the way that normally
we should treat justice but i guarantee
you that all of these cases will be
treated the same
always and forever because again the
elitists have to control this thing top
down
and individual justice requires that
there be due process and people be
treated individually and cases be
treated
individually that's a bad case that
requires serious thorough investigation
it is not the same as some of the other
cases that have been cited and lumping
them all together
is just a way of promoting a
collectivist narrative that is at odds
with reality
by the way there are consequences to
that collectivist narrative some
consequences
including elitists in our society
declaring that looting is okay
so i told you earlier this week that npr
published
a long interview with vicki osterweil
who's the author of a book called in
defense of looting
a riotous history of uncivil action npr
summarized the book as an argument that
looting is a powerful tool to bring
about real lasting change in society
so upscale white lady is defending
looting which disproportionately affects
minority communities graham wood
is a staff writer at the atlantic he
actually quotes the book
and the book is insane and it was given
the the it was given the
wonderful massage oils treatment by npr
according to graham wood looting is good
says osterweil because it exposes a deep
truth
about the great american con game which
is that without police and without state
oppression we can have things
for free the book was written in love
and solidarity with looters the world
over
she says that the so-called united
states was founded in cis hetero
patriarchal
racial capitalist violence and that
produced the current system
looting rejects the legitimacy of
ownership rights and property the moral
injunction to work for a living and the
justice of law and order
ownership of things is innately
structurally white supremacist
so the remedy is violence the
destruction of business
is quote an experience of pleasure joy
and freedom
riots are violent extreme and female as
f according to oscar wilde they rip
tear burn and destroy to give birth to a
new world
she says that martin luther king jr is
kind of a positive figure but definitely
would have been more of a positive
figure if uh if people had gotten hurt
she calls the i have a dream speech
quote the product of a series of
sellouts and silencings of non-violent
leaders
dampening the militancy of the
grassroots
she's more of a fan of assata shakur who
murdered a new jersey police officer
so good stuff oscar wilde quotes stokely
carmichael again the creator of the
institutional racism systemic racism
argument quote responsibility for the
use of violence by black men whether in
self-defense or initiated by them
lies with the white community so
osterweil again
pushing this elitist narrative she gets
to make the rules and gets to overthrow
the systems that allow for individual
freedom
in in pursuit of a narrative that leaves
elitists with power
now the funny thing about this is of
course the elitist in power end up being
eaten by the exact
sort of phenomenon they're pushing and
this is how you end up with the saint
louis mayor
now vacating his home thanks to the
protests in st louis
uh sorry her home rather so
if these protests are non-violent and
everything is hunky-dory and it's really
just about the system why do we now have
mayors running away from their houses
we just had mayor ted wheeler of
portland abandoning his condo because
people were firing
fireworks at it now we have st louis
mayor lita crewson
who is who has left her home fled her
home she's temporarily relocated after a
string of protests at her central west
end home
she confirmed she and her husband have
been living in an apartment in the
central west end she said we did it to
escalate the situation to de-escalate
the situation
to save police resources and importantly
because our neighbors were being
disturbed
and threatened so well done
everywhere well like this is just this
is all
it's all solid stuff the problem with
the elitist is that the elitists think
that they can control the system
and indeed the system ends up
controlling them it turns out that
violating the
the laws of rule and order and then
overthrowing them in favor of a new
birth of revolution
the people who think they're going to
run that thing end up being the first
people to the guillotines
and that is what you are watching in
essence play out
okay meanwhile president trump has been
taking action
against some of this stuff so president
trump has now ordered
the federal government he's ordered the
executive branch
to begin the process of cutting funds to
quote-unquote lawless cities that have
cut their police budgets
according to ryan's federal reporting
for daily wire president trump has
reportedly
ordered the federal government to
initiate a review that could result in
the defunding of four
democrat-controlled cities that have
allowed lawless behavior to transpire
during the protests
and that have moved to cut the police
while violent crime is surged trump said
in a memo quote
my administration will not allow federal
tax dollars to fund cities that allow
themselves to deteriorate into lawless
zones
to ensure that federal funds are neither
unduly wasted nor spent in a manner that
directly violates our government's
promise
to protect life liberty and property it
is imperative that the federal
government review the use of federal
funds
by jurisdictions that permit anarchy
violence and destruction in america's
cities
the order targets new york city portland
seattle and washington d.c
the memo also instructs a.g william barr
to compile a list of quote
anarchist jurisdictions that have quote
permitted violence and the destruction
of property to persist
and have refused to undertake reasonable
measures to restore order
now listen i'm a federalist which means
that i believe in
local rule it is also true the federal
government routinely attaches strings to
funds that go to
local government so if you want the feds
to sign the check then
i mean this has been long a tool of
american federal policy
the memo states that new york democrat
governor andrew cuomo and new york city
democratic mayor
bill de blasio quote allowed violence to
spike while resisting the president's
offer to send in federal law enforcement
while violence has surged arrests have
plummeted the memo says in a 28-day
period during the months of june and
july new york city arrests were down 62
percent
from the same period in 2019 amidst the
rising violence bill de blasio and the
new york city council agreed to cut one
billion dollars from the nypd
and cancel the hiring of 1163 officers
the memo also states that dc mayor
muriel bowser allowed writers and
anarchists to engage in violence and
destruction in late may and early june
requiring me to call in the national
guard to maintain law and order
in the nation's capital new york city
receives nearly 7 billion
per year in federal aid that could be on
the table
this is also ticked off mayor ted
wheeler i love this mayor ted wheeler
tweeted out
trump threatens to withdraw federal
funds possibly including health
education and safety net dollars
americans need to get through the
pandemic and economic crisis again
he targets cities including ours with
democratic mayors which he calls quote
unquote anarchist jurisdictions
literally this man had to abandon his
condo because of the anarchy he has
allowed to thrive
in his own city well all of this
prompted andrew cuomo your wonderful
governor of new york
to literally threaten the president with
violence so it is amazing this guy is
incredible he is he is the greatest
governor in the history of the united
states according to the media he carries
a 70
approval rating in a state where he
killed 11 000 seniors and still refuses
to hand over the stats on
nursing home deaths here was andrew
cuomo suggesting that uh trump better
have an army if he comes to new york
city
he can't come back to new york he can't
he's gonna walk down the street in new
york forget bodyguards
he better have an army if he thinks he's
going to walk down the street
in new york from the point of view of
new york city
this has been the worst president in
history look the best thing he did for
new york city
was leave
good riddance let him go to florida
be careful not to get covered wha what
what a nice guy remember this is the
nice guy the wonderful andrew cuomo
making death mountains out of paper
mache to demonstrate his own
amazing performance on kovid all angry
because the feds aren't going to
continue sending checks to a state that
he is
mishandling and and running incredibly
poorly i've been told by the way that
only trump has raised the temperature
here
only trump has raised the temperature it
doesn't matter that nancy pelosi has
engaged in
violent rhetoric or that andrew cuomo
openly suggests that president trump
might get assassinated if he walks the
streets of
new york city he's gonna need an army in
order to walk through new york city
which by the way like what's that what
is that intended to do do you think that
trump is then going to declare that you
have law and order in charge
of your city like literally trump is
like you don't have law order your
city's an anarchist jurisdiction
and the response is if he comes here
he's going to get shot by people
it seems like you're sort of making
trump's case for him there andrew just a
little bit
so you know trump's action on this uh is
uh well taken and certainly better taken
than a lot of the narrative issues that
are being pursued by democrats
rather than justice for individuals well
that's not to suggest that everything is
going well in trumpland
so yesterday the president was speaking
and he was talking about
mailing and mail-in voting and uh he
suggested
that people should vote twice in order
to
in order to test the mail-in system so
he's not really saying that you should
actually
physically go and vote twice what he's
saying is if you have so much faith in
the system you shouldn't mind if people
vote twice
if you think mail-in balloting is
wonderful then why exactly would it be a
problem for anybody to do this people
are of course taking this as though
trump was deliberately instructing
people to go vote twice here is what
trump had to say
let him send it in and let him go vote
and if the assistant's as good as they
say it is then obviously they won't be
able to vote
if it isn't japulated they'll be able to
vote so that's the way it is and that's
what they should do
okay so is is trump really urging people
vote twice violate federal law no he's
not but he's an irresponsible language
of course
and what trump should say there is is a
slightly different version of that which
is
the syste the system they're saying that
it's foolproof and everything is totally
fine you have to show voter id you can
vote any which way from sunday
that's going to lead to a lot of chaos
and if in fact people voted twice
then it could lead to significantly more
chaos they're obviously not that
confident i mean there's a reason why we
have
the federal crimes on the books to
prevent people from voting twice trump
instead goes where trump
always goes okay well this prompted bill
barr the ag to be asked about all of
this
about trump encouraging supporters to
supposedly vote illegally twice
here was bill barr's answer on cnn now
bill barr has a typical strategy when
asked about trump which is he pretends
trump doesn't exist
which by the way is the strategy of most
of the trump officials
whenever trump says something ridiculous
they'll just be like yeah whatever
that's trump saying stuff
which by the way is still the attitude
of most americans toward the stuff that
trump says here was bill barr doing that
well i don't know exactly what he was
saying but it seems to me what he's
saying
is he's trying to make the point that uh
the ability to monitor this system is
is not good and if it was so good if you
tried to vote a second time you would be
caught
if you voted in person that would be
illegal if they did that if somebody
mailed in a ballot and then actually
showed up uh to vote in person
uh that would be illegal i don't know
what the law on the particular state
says you can't vote twice
well i don't know what the law in the
particular state says and when that vote
becomes final any state that says you
can vote twice
well there's some you know maybe that
you can change your vote up to a
particular time i don't know what the
law is
okay that is uh that is awkward but what
bar is saying there is he doesn't know
if you send an absentee ballot and then
you go vote
if they don't finalize one of the
ballots is that illegal okay bottom line
here is that trump shouldn't have said
what he said but
it is pretty obvious that he's not
actually telling people go vote twice
he's actually saying if you guys are so
confident in the system why would you
have a problem with anybody
voting twice this led the uh estimable
chris cuomo
when he's not telling michael cohen not
to trust the media and that he's been
accused of sexual harassment
is interviewing his brother the greatest
governor in america
about his nostril size here's chris
cuomo going off on bill barr
it's a federal law would you like me to
read it to you la la la
i happen to have it you can look it up
you're not allowed to vote twice like
you need me to tell you that
can you believe the attorney general of
the united states is playing dumb
about something like that and why just
to help his boy
because he's a trumpet he's a pawn
as opposed to you know other ages who
are completely non-partisan now again
bill bar should just say it's illegal to
vote twice it is illegal to vote twice
is my understanding um but yeah again
the
the the media is outsized detention paid
to trump riffing
the narrative is always trump riffing is
is is the end of the world now
again should trump say that sort of
stuff of course from shouldn't say that
stuff we have all sorts of confusion
about this you know it's a bigger
problem to me universal mail in voting
itself here was bill barr yesterday
slamming universal mail and voting this
is a much more important commentary by
bill barry yesterday
this is a you know sort of cheap talk to
get around the fundamental problem
which is the bipartisan commission
chaired by jimmy carter
and james baker said back in 2009
that mail-in voting is fraught
with the risk of fraud and coercion
since then
until this administration let me talk
yeah please uh and since this since that
time
there have been in the newspapers in
networks
academic studies saying it is open to
fraud
and coercion the only time the narrative
changed is after this administration
came in
okay barr happens to be exactly correct
about this but of course the media are
all in favor of universal mail and
balloting because they believe
that it will help democrats they're
going to focus in on trump saying a dumb
thing about voting twice which nobody's
going to take him up on
meanwhile suggesting the voter fraud
literally doesn't occur and universal
mail in voting is no problem at all
which are
i i don't understand how media that
suggests voter fraud is nearly
impossible and doesn't occur anyway
why are they so deeply upset even if
trump said what they say he says like
trump shouldn't say it because he
shouldn't encourage people to commit
crimes obviously but apparently the
system is so safe that it's not a
problem anyway
so there we are that that is where
things stand you know the president
shouldn't step on himself
in all of this it is it is a mistake to
do so never interrupt your opponents
when they're making a mistake right now
democrats are making all sorts of
mistakes
the president shouldn't involve himself
in making exactly the same kind of
mistakes alrighty we'll be back later
today for two additional hours
of content joe biden is set to visit
kenosha so we'll bring you updates
on him visiting the family of a man who
was shot
apparently justifiably by police going
for a knife in his car after having
allegedly raped a woman
so we'll see how that goes and we'll
bring you all the updates you're
listening to the bench bureau show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haase our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wiedowsky our
associate producer is nick shien
the show is edited by adam syavette
audio mix by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
liberal elites double down on white
guilt nancy pelosi attacks the salon
owner who caught her breaking lockdown
rules and bill barr exposes the truth
about mail-in voting
check it out on the michael knowles show